hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the evil within a
nice moment of reprieve before we go
back into the horror and the fact that
there is horror in this game is a
welcome return I am I'm actually
enjoying it quite a lot I'm enjoying it
more
I mean oddly enough the only time just
in the past time that I'm playing it
I've been playing the all the episode
that you've been seeing so far in a row
the only time that I got frustrating is
when I was I had to do combat you know I
mean in the beginning of this
playthrough obviously I screwed up
trying to run away but that's because I
thought I needed to fight initially I
didn't know that I just needed to run
away so as soon as I did I was fine and
then when I had to fight that's when I
did that hello Joe Joe Joseph
wait not too late ah now he's going into
the agency well I didn't seem good so
that explains what the game was kind of
reintroducing itself with an
introduction that went very slow was not
too complex because it became a
different game with different intentions
okay so I need more
at least I'd open up that so if I can
get more I can go other places same
thing as in the first game well I say
first game but you guys know what I mean
just the first part of the game the main
game although I like this yeah it is
bizarre because I will admit like the
control room hello baby
literal baby are you doing excuse me
yeah the controls are a bit wonky
admittedly like hello why are there just
abandoned baby dolls around here it's
really disturbing it kind of adds to the
the panic nosov it because it doesn't do
what I want it to all the time and that
makes me really really freaking out just
because it's not cooperating with me and
that's both good and bad because it's
frustrating to some degree but also it's
good because this is really really crazy
awesome that it adds another layer hi
how's it going friends wait can I he'll
kick this cuz it used to be that I break
up everything trying to hoping to get
brain juice but I don't think that's a
case here yeah I don't think there's any
brain juice to be had in fact I'm pretty
sure the only reason I can kick in the
first place is to be able to stun
someone so that I can run away that's my
idea
woah woah please tell me I don't have to
run away from that oh no oh oh no also I
really don't know but this game like
this DLC here and I know it didn't come
out that much later than the original
game it looks way better and am I not
wrong in that like it seems like this is
play way way way
hi okay
there's a reason for this there's a
reason all hi ah don't wake the baby the
baby oh god damn it I'll get through the
baby I'm dead baby kill me go go go
please go please go please go
ghandar go please go fast please yes
okay so
now hello you're going so what I
probably need to do is I need to go over
this side fall it
hi come here come here I gave it that
come hither shout it's really effective
oh come on did that not work I don't
think it was close enough which is great
I have to be even closer to shout at him
to come here hey hey big boy
head big boy hey hey loser
come here nerd come here oh oh what the
Frick okay did that work was the X he
was a going okay so now I go now I go
now I go now I go now I go now I go okay
now is when I go now is when I go fast
mash mash like oh you share muscles okay
and we're probably not good for now
where was it oh okay by me oh oh I
wasn't fast enough
what the FAK Wow oh-oh-oh-oh
what the [ __ ] what's the [ __ ] and
running running running running not
standing still because standing still
means death go go go go go go go please
dear God go go go go faster no please
please please
all this couldn't be fly Oh was it more
just a little more just a little more
come on just a little more
one more come on all right let's go
buddy
okay let's go let's go okay we're going
we're on we're done we're done we're
done we're done Jesus that was crazy
difficult man why was that so intense
hey bear give me a goddamn checkpoint
over here because that was some bull
that I just went through give me your
view yes please thank you solidify that
is a cool mechanic by the windows whew
Nellie that is hard down here whoo I am
sweating stanking up this room real bad
oh okay
so alright that makes sense to me okay
is this gonna be like number six or
something and I missed all of them
that's number six oh I still missed more
I don't know like I've I've thought I've
been looking everywhere but apparently I
have definitely not there's probably
just like those subtle secrets like that
I gotta shine my light on light on or
something that I've been missing or like
the pathways like up that I thought
maybe I could climb up but I didn't oh
man hello baby
you uh you got reseated that's cool good
good good good
oh man I can't believe that one monster
gave me so many heart attacks I swear I
fought that monster before and I only
have two of these now I gotta get a
total of three wait no right there or no
not that okay I need two we said that
okay I got that so that opens there so
I'm gonna be able to get a third final
fuse for that I guess I could just put
this one here just for comfort sake
I mean not like it matters I mean I
don't think that thing can come after me
up to a few ladders or whatever but this
is a lot of work just to get to Jojo I
will admit well see what see if it's
worth it
I thought I heard that sounds a static
but it was just those water
is so much better oh oh that's oh oh I
thought that was I thought that was the
same door as like when it Castellanos
safe rooms okay but at least has a place
to hide so I can come in here if need be
which I imagine I will need be whoa whoa
trap death trap okay I think I caught
that one he's dumb a little observant
hello anybody home
anybody want to try to kill me I bet
there's lots okay well I was almost too
easy
sure I'm glad that was the thing that it
was Wow all right so what horrible thing
is gonna happen oh that's good oh that's
good
oh that's good wait that's Leslie isn't
that what Leslie does hello oh no I
uh hey can walk through the traps hey
come here hey come on come the [ __ ] are
you are you freaking are you freaking me
are you freaking me forgive me right now
haha in here get in hi he'll never find
me in here
I'm untraceable oh I can't look I see
Mara
all that miss him what the Frick
come here you there oh okay well this is
less than ideal whoa ah [ __ ]
oh crap closing closing closing closing
closing closing okay all right that's
okay we're okay that guy doesn't look
happy over there that's okay
Jesus
hello hi hello friends okay this ain't
good huh BAM he'll kick and leave me
jump grabby honey fly me up e and safety
way fee well that was marginally easier
if I didn't know oh hey how's it going
uh I'm gonna do this thing before you
decide to ruin my day
okay whoa cool cool yeah it's great
looking at this cutscene at all but I
think they have the capability to climb
up a ladder oh no they don't they can't
even jump down bye-bye now
take care then all right moving right
along
please I have a gun in my holster I mean
no bullets but and that wasn't using
this for anything but where's Jojo all I
care right about now finding Jojo Jojo -
Jojo easier Jojo here this looks
unreturnable Joe Joe Joe Joe Joe Joe Joe
see you're all right you two
thank God any sign Sebastian nothing
maybe we can go back and look for him
no I mean let's just get out of here
first then we can worry about Sebastian
can we open our key I doubt you and I
are strong enough
Joseph watch it I'll be fine
quick look around see if there's another
way out yeah
could I have some of your bullets no
actually keep them all for yourself
that's totally ok man that was
definitely pointing out the difference I
was right they definitely upped uh
Kidman's model to look with way better
features and looking at Jojo up close
you could tell like that was an older
model and it was like less detail I
don't know if like this DLC was intended
for the next generation things what's
this game I don't know if the
kitty-kitty-kitty-kitty come back hello
little kitty how are you doing are you
doing kill you hey kitty how you doing
good kid saved my whole life for me ok
now get off one pets all you get I want
to be do greedy with you yeah well that
was a brief encounter with Jojo but
there he was and off to save the day
again
good thing up well this explains more
why kid ninjas
Jojo Sebastien Castellano hmm maybe not
that way just yet what's over here
ah knew there was a secret
how about for a scrap that I is not
gonna be any useful for me whoa yes
hello
alrighty then uh that's a little weird
oh I get it
okay ah alright so yeah there we go
wait no hang on who's that
I had it there we go
BAM I did it or something is that a
scrap these puzzles aren't very
difficult oh no it's a team they've
refocused the efforts of the other
programs to support our research good
stem priority has seemingly overridden
other departments individual research
uh-huh chemical and botanical studies
are focused now on temporary priming
subjects for their inevitable connection
right now that the prototype is up and
running experiments continue upon their
return from stem integration patients
are interviewed extensively right while
their particular pathologies inform
their experiences there are
commonalities they all experience the
same settings the same occurrences the
world they inhabit becomes larger with
every new visitor this suggests that
shards of each users consciousness are
left behind inside the stem creating a
community
it's as if internally a new world is
being built yeah that's why it's called
the evil within is so Medan [ __ ] right
that is cool to know because it's
explaining what we already knew about
how this world was pieces of what
everyone understood already but I mean
it's still good to know that it's
explained out in the open and accepted
but I would like some new information
be nice where's musting focus kid I
warned you about that
yeah could this place exist I don't
understand what's happening in here
uh-huh
knows you're here he's feeding off you
gross there are more important problems
that Detective Division something to
worry about he doesn't suspect it he's
expendable how else do you want me to
say it remove him
that's an order cute Joseph that's not
gonna help me find Leslie he can't be
trusted
he'll turn on you they all will once
they know what you're after we told you
you're weak kid
and you're disappointing us Wow are you
guys all right we're all right Sebastian
maybe we can lift this enough for Kidman
to go under and open it from the other
side we're counting on you that's so
weird
so she was like having a completely
different series of just killing you
maybe he didn't see me as a threat
hey yo Jono I know who you are I'm not
going to let you take him you should
have followed your orders kid
okay
hi no no no coward come out damn it I
don't want to no no I don't want to oh
there's got to be a better way no he can
survive a harpoon in the head not an axe
oh no not George oh this is in the
reunion I wanted not no no way I'm not
gonna do it No oh crap
well this is fun I'll just stay here
that that is inexcusable how wimpy that
is well what does that do
that's probably a waste couldn't have
gone far
hey I wonder how far this light can go
inside your brain oh oh so let's go
through here foot wait Oh over there
whoops I was at the completely wrong
area there we go
oh I don't want to Sam alright let's do
it
Wow
[ __ ] you Kidman oh if you bad not juju
hmm oh is it coming around the other way
snakey snakey see oh just let me get a
clean shot you couldn't have gone far
I might have gone far again with the
amount of gone farness whoa God what the
rock oh come on what the [ __ ] why did
why Jesus man Oh what oh there we go
okay got him got him got him prepare for
the final whammy I was saving this one
why are you making me do this dude oh
damn it Joseph you should have just
stayed out of the way
are there sins you are ashamed of Oh
Jojo
wait a second this house no it can't be
oh hello well that's not creepy at all
yeah mother was sit in her chair rocking
back and forth killing time until the
next service she barely spent any time
with us I wondered why she even had
children at all Oh miss kiddin please
tell me about your family next subject
no we prolonged this talk for a while
now
it's important for our understanding of
you they never gave a [ __ ] too caught up
in that church of theirs more like a
cult it was like a punishment nothing I
ever did was good enough for them they
abused you
no it was more like neglect that's why
when I just left they didn't care they
never came looking I just gave up and
you never went back to I did a couple of
years later they were gone everyone was
gone it was like the whole town got up
and moved I should have felt something
but I didn't and how do you feel about
it now the same they can rot for all I
care it was strange though there's a
statue in the center of town an angel
with its head in its hands I used to
just stare at it when I was young
thinking it was sad but now I felt like
even that statue knew how pitiful life
was there what a terrible place sounds
like a great childhood at least we're
getting more back story on Kidman here
that's some nice blood there great so
why am I here I have a feeling that
Rubik playing some tricks on me
that explains this this was from Kidman
oh okay
that's so weird I remember this in the
original game ah that's so crazy so many
finer details it's all interwoven can't
wait to play the other DLCs do you see
how they fit it apparently in the final
DLC the executioner you actually play as
one of the creatures in the game I think
you play as Lochhead guy not sexy legs
McGee uh that's a good name sexy legs
Leslie Leslie stop Leslie stop okay well
that's not convenient oh good the
statues gone - don't stare up at the
statue lit up in the center of town yeah
it's so great is crying for all the
wasted life in that place uh-huh cool so
ruvik indeedy-do got a tap on my
memories so what am I supposed to do I
know about that searchlight I might have
shot one of them okay so I'm assuming if
I put this up in the center of town
it'll make things go away it might make
things go a better
I'm not darling sure
let's go right here Wow I was like okay
I turn that one on Bing bong magical
statue gonna appear sorry uh-huh
time okay so uh so what about that oh I
got you okay I'm the last light cool I
did it
I smarted I smarted all over the place I
think I actually need a save point
pretty soon I haven't saved since I
killed Jojo is Jojo really dead no I
mean I know at the end of the original
game whoa
oh yeah isn't this where I met the dog
Oh
in life we constantly search for place
we feel see uh-huh can always come back
we imagine that place in our minds and
are drawn to it right at a home but now
that place is here with us
cool thanks for the wise words of wisdom
oh there's a safe point hi kitty
I'm a common I'm on my way hello kitty
hello weird symbols oh okay kitty uh did
he stay away from those I don't think
you want anything to do with those
they're still twitching all right kitty
hop in my lap lap hop B up B up B up up
get me kitty oh you so cute adorable
love the red ribbon okay all right
whoo this was a stressful emotional
episode I can't believe it Jojo no whoo
no all right so thank you everybody so
much for watching I really do wonder if
there was another way that I could have
done that I don't know I went through
that whole place I thought I was running
away but mmm that's so sad it's so
dad go well either way thank you
everybody so much for watching I'm gonna
keep playing in another session it's
like why in the morning I gotta go to
bed now so thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video oh yeah II what
I'm doing this in general [ __ ] does
that stand for the penis part does that
stand for these prongs are fresh